because the elderly are really
susceptible to the coronavirus
they're not watching anyone's kids
they're not doing anything here
they used to get your grandparents and
other people to do so this whole
thing has cost my people such a rest
that
they're not working on top of that you
can't get the assistant
uh because it's slow they don't have
enough workers to help us
uh you can't get assistance because we
can't even give people you have to go to
orientation
to get assistance that they have
orientation
because you can't have overseeing people
or you know what's going on to corona so
it's really
devastating to my people who are hard
workers uh our director could tell you
we were
excited for our quality we had the best
quality and all the promises
uh like i said i never forget him coming
letting us know
that usd was opening four new plants and
my plan closed so a lot of things that
was said
nothing has come to petition
my name is michael miller i put 47 years
in the steel mill
i got laid off on april florida i'm a
third generation steel worker
and with that being said when young
people came into my plant
i became their male dad i was there long
enough to be able to teach them
to be able to be safe follow the rules
to understand it we got paid we've got
good wages wages that these people
bought cars
homes put their kids in better
education so now these same people
women men or are we laid off
to replace a job and the
skills that they have aren't really
transformable
in the world because they're still still
working
if you just don't put a job on the line
i'm still working
unless you're going into another steel
plant those qualities and skills
are worn and taught through sops and
standards
and all of a sudden now they're looking
at 10 to 15
hour jobs that only take
a minimum of half of what they used to
make
and a lot of these children have
issues with i medication my services
spear i don't know where i could
possibly use but it's scary i'm at the
end of my
career and i'm looking forward to social
security
that we paid into and
i'm trying to use the flight work for
the man that's in the white house
doesn't seem to have a plan except to
take
our social security medicare my wife and
i are
at the point where we we earned those
rights we paid into those
we cannot take what is not yours but for
some reason
they think they can we need you to go in
there
and we need harris to go in there and we
need people like you to take initiative
back
i want my country back i want the
country that you guys
for eight years ran this country where
people want to sleep at night
knowing that they have jobs in the
morning they have security
they have somebody going to plan and
with your plan
i'm with you i'm seriously
need for michigan to carry you
wake up and get out and push the boat i
can't
thank you enough for asking me to be
here because the fact that we need
michigan
we need you in washington we need to
take this
to the fight it is a fight people
really need to understand that thank you
uh my name is tim petrovsky i'm
president of local 1900
out of south lyon uh first of all i'd
like to
thank you for being here and meeting
with us it means a lot
to know what you'll do for later uh at
our plant
we are much smaller than andrea's plant
you know we only have around
this time last year we had 250 members
we're down to about 140 so it's
you know the promise of building
manufacturing jobs here in michigan just
hasn't happened
you know they've been on the steep
decline and
as my brother said here if you can find
a job which there are a few out there
it's
it's 12 bucks an hour 14 bucks an hour
and for
people that have been working 20 30
years working hard in the steel mill
they've earned the right to a good union
wage and what we need here in michigan
and what i believe you can bring to
michigan joe is good paying
union jobs that's what we need it's more
good paying
union you know i work hard every day
i put in 40 to 60 hours a week every
week
and i live a good life i live a good
life i give live a good union right
and you know i may not live in a million
dollar home
but what i do have i'm proud of i'm
proud to raise my [ __ ]
my children in the middle class
neighborhood and
and there's always steak in the freezer
you know and and that's something
that i i would like to see more
opportunity out here in michigan
so again thank you for being here well
thank you talked very
briefly michael i uh
i come from a town where people lost a
lot of jobs grant pennsylvania
and then i moved to a town it used to
have six thousand two hundred steel
workers
worst deal in clermont delaware it was
uh
that yeah that was the town that was the
town
and uh there's nothing there now
nothing there and one of the things that
i see happening all the time is that
most hard-working folks they're not
looking for any handouts
of an opportunity just a shot it's a
shot to make it
and the women and men i grew up with
busted their neck and were able to live
and be somewhere my dad used to have an
expression he said joey
when he lost his job up in scranton
moved down
his cleaning boilers and roman condella
over here
and raised as a kid and then he moved to
scranton high school um
you used to say joe your job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's about being able to replace
in the community but let me look your
kid in the eye and say honey it's gonna
be okay
and mean before this pandemic that the
president
left it totally out of control uh
you know middle-class folks were getting
hurt
and uh people were offshoring jobs talks
about how
we're going to take care of making sure
that uh you know
we created more jobs that was the
promise he made out here the automobile
industry
the steel industry etc you know
the issue is if the american
worker gets to have a shot they're the
best competitor in the world
i mean for real not a joke you can
compete with anybody
given half a shot and uh but look what's
happened
you know when we did all those gigantic
tax cuts when we got elected we found
ourselves in a position where
they were rewarding corporations to move
offshore
to send their jobs offshore and uh
so uh i have a plan that's called
buildback better it's not
but one of the things i announced today
the uaw is that
if you have a government contract
federal government has a lot of
control over a lot of things if you use
taxpayers money
and you hire people to build things or
make things for the
for the united states you have to do it
with american labor
you have to deal with american business
and what that means is that
uh we're in a situation now where so
much of it
you now get a tax break if you go abroad
for example if you were to uh
um like the drug companies
the drug companies have to manufacture
medicines that we need
well if you move the plant overseas you
don't get any
it doesn't cost you anything you don't
get any penalty
about seven thousand dollars overseas
but what happens is
when you bring it back much cheaper wage
being paid
for the portion that your company in the
in the states the
fact that you have mistakes you bring it
back you pay
there's no penalty for doing that what
i'm going to change
is make sure that anybody who offshores
anything they're going to pay a 10
surtax and anything they bring back in
so that we can't you got to stop it
and conversely if you come along and
someone is going to
open up a steel mill someone's going to
open up
an automobile facility open up any
facility they're going to make
build it or expand something or increase
wages
for labor what happens is you get a 10
search you get a 10 credit will pay for
10 percent
government of anything you built so
you're building a new
shop and it's gonna cost you a hundred
thousand bucks just to give and make it
easy
you get ten thousand dollars that ten
percent of that gets paid for by the
federal government
so we encourage people to come home
and we desperately cause people to go
abroad
but one of the biggest things going on
you talked about
uh you know everything from who should
be paid and how they should be paid
when we did the recovery act
after the last recession we inherited
brock and i
we uh i was able to get past i was asked
to do it i was able to convince
three of my republican colleagues to
change their vote we got it passed
and it even the conservative office said
it saved us from a depression
but what we did was we appropriated
800 billion dollars almost a trillion
dollars
and we invested it in america that
created significant number of jobs
and we did it in a way for example a lot
of the states out right now
they're they're they're basically going
bankrupt
they have to balance their budgets the
reason the founders are smart enough not
to say the federal government had to do
so it could be a balance when in fact
things are going down
well what do we do we put an awful lot
of money for example
i was in charge of doing it and the
president
gave me the authority to do it he put
140 billion dollars in the states
so he kept every firefighter police
officer school teachers we kept
everybody employed
it didn't have to be laid off so they
continue to build now what we should be
doing here
is we should be making sure that we mean
what we say
we say by america we have a proposal for
a
when when the president allowed me to
run that program
we're the largest infrastructure project
in building roads and bridges and
ports and like since when eisenhower
booked the interstate highway system
and as a consequence of that we were
able to pour
billions of dollars into the economy and
if you notice
every one of those jobs that and i
insist that they'd be
prevailing wage it had to be union wage
if you're going to work it you had to be
a prevailing wage you could not get the
contract
if you in fact were paying somebody 15
bucks an hour
and so we began to grow how long this
guy comes and decides that
that doesn't make he keeps talking about
infrastructure
how we're going to need significantly
more steel and cement uh
all these things we hadn't offered one
single thing
he said he had an infrastructure project
was going to start
in 2016 2017 2018
2019 2020 not one single thing
in the meantime a lot of your
your fellow employees that they get laid
off
in order and closed down a lot of these
companies are going under
and what's happening is they're losing
their health insurance they
have paid into all these years and
what's he doing
he's out there trying to eliminate a
flat eliminate
the existing health care system that
exists you talk about social security
and medicare
you know i was talking about this for a
long time and people thought i was
kidding
well he has a proposal it sounds like
sounds real good to do away with
the the payroll tax for the employer
employee
that you're going to put more money in a
salary but guess what
by the year 2023 the social security
actuary said social security will be
busted done over not a penny to be able
to pay
anybody their social security what tells
that all that
and then you remember when republican
congress tried to cut
the medicare are several billion dollars
what are we doing here we should be
expanding this not
cutting it not cutting it and
here's the bottom line if we
insist which i will i promise you
and if we can win back the senate which
i think we will
we're going to be able to get this done
if we insist that
you have to make it in america and build
it in america
we're able to do that without violating
international trade agreements that
exist now so for example
all that steel that's going to go into
uh
building new facilities all that steel
that's going into for example when we
when we in fact uh you know the
president has a 600
billion a year budget for things that
are
going into american made
products but american-made initiatives
so for example
lightweight stale aluminum on the new
decks of aircraft carriers
none of that stuff should be made
anywhere else but in the united states
of america
by american state period guaranteed
not a single thing you know i was in a a
small steel mill up in scranton
pennsylvania in archival pennsylvania
they make railings and steps well guess
what
that all that aluminum that they're
making and all that steel they're
doing it's a small outfit but what's
happening
they're being there's competition from
abroad selling it cheaper nothing
happened
it's going to have to be any railing put
in an
american ship or a building built by the
united states of america
has to be made in america and
so it's not you know it's just simple
these are taxpayers dollars we're
spending for example
we're in a situation now where you know
china is in a position where they're
trying to
become the leading automaker of
electric vehicles in the world well
guess what
if we in fact make the investments which
we're going to make
one of the largest auto fleets in the
world is owned by the federal government
we're going to move every one of those
vehicles to electric vehicles we're
going to then put 500 000
charging stations along our highways the
ibw
going to be able to put in we're going
to be in a situation where we're going
to
literally create over a million jobs
i not 15 bucks an hour but 48 bucks an
hour with benefits and growing
because a lot of you guys busted your
neck a lot of you guys have busted your
neck and you work like the hell
and you can make anywhere from 75 to 100
000 bucks
busting your neck you can live a decent
life
you can live a decent life to talk about
what happens now the choices have to be
made
for you know a parent who has a job
and has to make a choice now between
whether or not they're going to stay
home with their kid because the school's
closed
they can't because it's as remote
learning
or go to work how in god's name can they
afford i was a single dad for five years
after my wife and daughter were killed
i tell you what i couldn't and i was
making a decent salary as the u.s
senator was 20
30 years old was making 42 000 bucks i
couldn't afford
someone to be full-time taking care of
my kids
they were four three and four years i
couldn't do it thank god i had a mom and
a dad and a
brother and a sister who were able to do
it but most people don't have that
and so we provide for example you know
we got all these look what his tax cut
did i think i have
okay right now if you have a capital
gain
because of an investment in a stock we
should be rewarding work not just well
if you in fact were to change the
capital gains income the charge of this
regular income
like your take your like you charge
taxes on your income that would generate
another 730
billion dollars in income over 10.
if you change the tax rate it went from
38 to 21.
you just sent it back to 20 over 38
down if you're 36 28.
that's what he started to try to do but
if he went down to 21.
he took the test back up to 28 that
raises 1 trillion
300 billion dollars these corporations
aren't hiring more people in order to do
on the tax break they got
they're buying back their stock they're
not hiring more people
and their ceos are getting raises and
they're
and they're stockholders they think the
only obligation is their stockholders
how about the people who work there
how about people work here we're not
even competitive anymore because we're
not invested in the future
if we end what they call stepped-up
basis if somebody
if tomorrow somebody dies
and their parent was uh they they had a
gain
you know somebody went out and bought
stock
and it gained once there was a ten
dollars and when he
dies it's at thirty dollars if he sold
that stock
you'd have to pay a capital gain on that
on that 30 bucks that it went up
but guess what it's a thing called
stepped-up basis
if you leave it to your kid they don't
have to pay a single penny
other than what it was when you bought
the stock
even though if you had sold it the day
before you died you'd have to pay
the capital gains on the game like
everybody else would have to
that's 440 billion dollars
i'm not going through all of it but
here's the deal guys every single thing
i talk about
i pay for by making sure for the first
time
the wealthy begin to pay what they
should be paying we're not going to
punish anybody
no make under 400 000 bucks which is
more money than i've ever made
is going to be able to it's going to
have to pay more taxes but guess what
the corporate you have 19 corporations
making billions of dollars each they
don't pay a single penny in taxes
not one penny nothing nothing
i mean if you just if you just tax them
you're talking about another
uh what are we talking about another 340
billion dollar so my point is that we're
not punishing anybody just making sure
people start paying their fair share
you bust your neck and you pay
at the rate you're supposed to pay
period
it doesn't matter you don't get any
break there's a consequence of it
the reason i bother to mention it you
mentioned about people having to make a
choice
we right now because i have we can
afford to do it
by these tax credits being eliminated
over time
is that nobody should have to pay
more than seven percent of their income
for child care
period so if you're making
a hundred thousand bucks a year you
can't don't to pay more than seven
thousand if you're making
more than making a hundred dollars you
don't make more than seven dollars my
point is
everybody could afford to have child
care that needed it for young kids who
are all
not in school look what's going on in
schools right now
there's a reason they're not open
because you can't safely open them
and every single expert pointed out that
you need to give those schools
income to be able to make to sanitize
the schools
make them safe so kids can in fact be in
a position
they can go to school and not become not
get covered
well guess what we this this
president refuses even though the
congress passed it
but the democratic house passed it
refuses to give any money to the states
to be able to provide for opening
schools
we used to have fema you know the
emergency management well they started
off it used to be a proposal that
that it was essential that it was
national
it was essential that we have schools
open
so we started to make sure that if in
fact you open the school
fema would pay for the cost of making
sure the school was safe
making sure there was separation making
sure there were sanitary meetings and
all the rest
well they did that for two schools and
all
the president comes along says it's not
essential it's not an emergency
so now guess what's happening a lot of
these schools aren't opening
they're not open because they don't have
the money to sanitize they have the
money to put up the
plastic barrier they have the money to
make sure they
can try for the equipment whether it's a
mask
or whether it's it's disinfectant to
make sure there's sanitary conditions in
the school
and we now know and the president
apparently knew for a long time
everybody now knows that you know what
the air you breed makes a big difference
if you don't have ventilation in the
school guess what
you increase exponentially likelihood
someone's going to get cold
the child may not die but he comes home
and the elderly father a mother who has
cancer or has a problem in fact ends up
getting it they die
and so it just makes no sense there's so
much we can do
just by making sure people start to pay
a fair share no one's gonna have to pay
more
you can be making a billion dollars you
don't have to make more than
you don't have to pay more than 39.5
percent of your income
and you guys pay close to that if you're
making 100 grand already
so my point is that it just drives me
crazy
that the country is going to hell on the
handbasket economically
and politically and in terms of our
health
and we're doing nothing about it we're
not doing a thing about it but there's
answers to these things
this is not about what's the president
doing
we keep from being able to have us
focusing on that and try to scare the
hell
out of you watch out man black lives
matter they're going to come and get you
and burn down your city
look violence is violence protest
everybody's a freedom of speech you're
allowed to protest period
but anybody who torches a car smashes
windows breaks into the store
i don't care who they are it's illegal
it's wrong
it's violence it should be arrested if
you can arrest them but notice this guy
the only thing he does is just pour you
know fuel on the flames
talks about how they're coming for you i
mean this is
it's all about the vision we have a
chance to unite the country
and by the way the idea that we're going
to be in a situation we're going into
the middle of the
second portion of the 21st century
and we don't have we don't have the
steel capacity
steel steel to make sure we can continue
to build this country
and invest in technology that's needed
one of you guys are talking about how
we have accomplished and acquired the
technological capability of doing
anything anybody else can and we can in
many cases
do it well and do it cheaper but guess
what
these in china remember what we did when
they started dumping steel
you put gigantic tariffs on them they
stopped dumping the steel
well it's just wrong the way we're going
about it but it's all about
making sure the big guy continues to do
very well
and unions are crushed
think about it look
one of the the piece of good news we
have is
i got in trouble about 15 years ago for
saying
that the chamber of commerce and uh and
corporation declared war on labor
and even when i spoke to flco national
convention hey
you had your right and guess what
declared war on labor
my dad another especially anybody the
only way you can fight abuse
of power is with power the only
power we can put together is union power
not a joke you're the guys that keep the
barbarians on the other side of the gate
and for the first time for the first
time
in over 50 years a majority of the
american people
say they want they want unions and they
join
the majority majority of the american
people
highest it has been in 50 years
because people are all sudden realizing
you're the only guys that have the power
to do anything you're the only guys that
keep them in the game
what happens is if you're not a member
of a union you find yourself if you've
an hourly work you have to sign a
non-compete agreement
i work for jimmy john's sandwich place
and i can't go across town to mcdonald's
to get five cents more
what's it all about depressing wages
that's all it's about or
overtime guess what you
reclassify as management management
because you're the person that grocery
shorter controls the person who brings
the card out that has the spaghetti
sauce on it
now your management you control the car
you know the deal
but people are finally waking up and
realizing the reason that any overtime
any of these things is because of unions
unions and by the way you know the fair
labor standards act way back in the
time of roosevelt and said you can have
unions it didn't say that
it said that not only unions allowed and
said we should encourage your
unions promote unions that's what it
says
promote unions and so
that's what this is all about balancing
the power
so people have a fighting chance
to make a case for their worth
that's what it's about what it's getting
but it's been absolutely
decimated but we can bring it back i
mean we really can
with your help with union health you
guys and women standing up
we can bring it back because like i said
you have you know 60 american people
saying they join a union now
that's when's the last time we heard
that was the last time you heard that
but they figured it out and look it used
to be a basic bargain i'm going to stop
talking here it used to be a basic
bargain
if you contributed to the well-being of
the enterprise you worked with
you got to share in the benefits so if
the company did well you did well
the company did poorly you did poorly
that's all been
blown apart that doesn't work that way
anymore
when corporations do well you don't
benefit from it
unless you're part of a union you can
negotiate for it
you don't benefit from it what do they
do they go by
buy back their own stock raising the
price of the stock
shareholders get benefits and then what
happens
the ceos end up
making a lot it used to be the ceo don't
want the exact number
but i think it was 30 years ago ceos
made
something like 38 times as much as the
average employee
in the corporation now it's over 400
times
what the hell happened and here's the
bad part
even they're beginning to figure out
some of these guys
because they're eating their own seed
corn they're not investing in anything
they're not investing in research and
development what are they doing
they're making the cook kit and they
know it's good they're going to get the
hell out but they're going to have these
gigantic salaries
we can change it the american public is
onto it
and i think we can really begin to
change it the first thing we have to do
is we've been around for 100 years made
in america
we got to mean it enforce it enforce it
make it in america and when in fact it's
taxpayers dollars so
there's a lot i think we can get done
but do you guys want to ask me some more
questions about anything
at all well one of the key things and
i'm glad you touched on and i wanted to
hear that my members wanted to hear that
about the increasing need for unions is
because that's a
safe place where women especially
women of color or other women we could
make equal amount of money
as to me that's what we love about
unions and the right of the young
youth if you have a parent like me i'm a
single mom and the reason why
unions will prevail for you we really
need you
to address this and keep our health care
and expand on that because my oldest ass
lucas so we're having lupus uh
she couldn't get in the military because
the air force wouldn't let her in
because her condition
now she wants you know she's a lawyer
and that helped me with the obamacare to
keep her on my insurance until she was
26.
that's right okay so then my son
uh he's autistic and this is very
something that people need to understand
and i want you to understand uh that
special education
even if you can go the kids if you find
that
centered at vegas city how do you find
center for children
special needs it's already horrible to
find somebody essential worship
but it's a person like me president of
my local and i'm still trades i'm
electrician by trade
at u.s steel and the union job allowed
me to get traded allow me to the company
pay for me to get a skill
that's suppliable here in the country
and that's that's a lot of things that
unions do
actually pay for you to go to uh
education to get skilled
and then my youngest just being a
college student now at michigan state
university she can't go to school
because of pandemic they don't let the
undergrads go to the things that she's
going through but all these parents who
work with parents
that i have and hear from the question
they want from you and now you pretty
much asked the main question was
not that should you promise because i'll
be honest my people were really in fear
because the promise is made
it doesn't kept but now you explained
they wanted you to explain how this
you're going to go about it
because they aren't keeping
manufacturing jobs but you strained a
lot
exactly well how you were gonna bring
them let me tell you one of the things
how we're gonna do
you know the aca
um there's a law
that was passed saying children with
disabilities
would be able to get special education
we could be educated to degrees which
are educated
and we've never funded it it's never
been fully funded in school
i'm going to make sure we fund it
totally
funded so number one you get the kind of
help that's needed
when the child with the autism or any
other
problem they're able to go to school and
be educated to the degree to which
they can with specialist educators
number one
number two you talk about whether or not
someone your daughter with lupus
well guess what not only did what we
passed make sure that she sustained the
policy
until she was 26 but that she could not
be charged more for a pre-existing
condition
over 100 million people have a
pre-existing initiative
what that meant was when in fact
when in fact they were going for
insurance themselves
the insurance company could charge an
exorbitant amount of money for the
pre-existing condition
they cannot do that now under the law
he's trying to get rid of that law right
now what i'm going to do
and i've laid it out and fighting for
and we're going to get it done
is three things number one we're going
to make sure that
in the obamacare if you don't have the
money
if you qualify for medicaid and the
state doesn't have medicaid for it
you automatically can enroll in a
medicare-like plan
under this what they call the option in
the biden plan
it's going to add on what brock and i
wanted to do when we put it together
it means that if you don't have the
money you automatically will be fully
covered
without having to pay anything for a
medicare-like plan
within obamacare if you are
wanting to get a goal plan for an
obamacare we subsidize it costs a lot of
money
my program will cost about 750 billion
over 10 years because we make people we
considerably lower the payment
you have to pay to get into the highest
rate of plans
we reduced drug prices significantly
nobody was going to be able to charge
for a drug that in fact unless they go
before
a board like you do in other countries
of experts made up
and say how much did you spend in
researching and developing this drug
you get to make a significant profit i
call
13 of these drug companies together when
i was doing
the so-called when i put together i was
asked to put together a whole proposal
relating to cancer and arrest and i got
them all together and i said what do you
think you should be able to charge for a
drug
that can save someone's life with a rare
disease they say whatever the market
will bear
i said wrong the only thing you can
charge is you get a reasonable return on
the investment you made
just like the utility company and so now
it's going to have to happen and we'll
get this passed because even some
republicans agree with you on this
what's going to happen is you'll go and
most drugs are now
bio-based drugs not chemical based drugs
the ones that are
dealing with the immune system
but so we're a drill company
i go and i want to get a package for the
drug company
okay for my product that is a real
life life
outside experts and they set the price
and when the price is set they can make
a significant profit
but they can't we're doing a departure
and shot they do that they cannot raise
the price beyond the cost of inflation
unless they demonstrate that they've
done something new to change
like
there's nothing there's nobody here